[Musique]
mais non des bâches vous pouvez zoomer
secret aurélien
granet
[Musique]
c'est un baiser chehoumi ils ont cru
qu'ils l'avaient que dalle c'est moi qui
les ai je la rendrai pas
je vous raconte pas comment j'ai
bataillé pour l'avoir mais gelé enfin il
est là j'ai pu le prendre des marches
iommi s'en sont pas rendu compte mais je
la gardais je l'aï si c'est le pad 5
c'est la toute première tablette de chez
sony qui vient d'arriver ici en france
si vous aimez shiomi si vous aimez la
masse si vous avez déjà un smartphone de
chez home il voulait étendre
l'écosystème de chirurgie pas de 5 c'est
ça qui est intéressant
[Applaudissements]
comme c'est la première fois qu'on a une
tablette chez au milk qui arrivent en
france c'est intéressant de voir
l'intérieur du conteneur de le bihac
moss dolby vision sur le côté pas grand
chose de bien folichon demi point com et
non des produits j'ai ainsi giga de ram
128 giga de stockage
à l'échec vous marquent les informations
principales ici à venir tenir sur la
fiche technique à savoir un écran wqs
des plus 120 hertz compatible dolby
vision ça c'est intéressant on voit
qu'on a du deuil billette modo c'est
toute la partie audio avec quatre haut
parleurs hockey instinct dragon 860
gravé en 7 nanomètres qui est
intéressant avec cette partie là lust un
dragon 860 c'est qu'on voit que dans la
série 8 de qualcomm qui est le plus haut
de gamme chez qualcomm donc de la
performance et une batterie de 8720
milliampères heures avec un chargeur de
22.3 inclure la boîte c'est quoi sa
carte de garantie et ça c'est un petit
guide de démarrage rapide port de
charges pour le smart peine on voit
qu'on a un connecteur pour clavier
shiomi moi j'ai ni le smartpad cahier
shiro mi mai on voit qu'effectivement et
bien va arriver un clavier chioui donc
on va pouvoir venir transformer ce padd
cinq ans petit ordinateur donc ça c'est
plutôt sympa ensuite blog de charge a
priori c'est ça usbco usb ensuite la
tablette landais le premier truc qui
devient vous tape à l'oeil c'est le
design qui est repris au niveau de la
gamme 11 chez chéreau richie a omis on
se tait on se tait pro c'est ce module
photo donc on a une vraie cohérence au
niveau de la gamme bouton ici pour nous
dans l'allumé pouvait venir monter
baisser le volume ici ça c'est le
connecteur pour venir recharger votre
smart peine que je n'ai pas deux la
recharge en usb seller des haut parleurs
le micro sur le dessous ici le
connecteur pour le clavier voyez c'est
très simple on est sur une version ici
wifi c'est pas une version d'icade génie
5g 349 euros pour la version 628 s'il ya
du stockage et 399 euros pour la version
6 giga de ram 256 go de stockage mon
point de vue l'expérience logiciel
qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver bas c'est
assez classique c'est la chose qu'on
connaît déjà on est sur un android bien
évidemment on est sur un android qui est
basée sur me wade c'est du new wave 12.5
c'est très classique on connaît déjà
l'expérience miroir xiaomi chose qui
marche vraiment très très très bien ira
d il ya un truc assez intéressant style
us inc qui bordent c'est le seul truc
qui n'est pas traduit c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'en fait ça montre
vraiment qu'il ya un stylet qui va
arriver potentiellement ailleurs s'il
n'est pas traduit est ce qui va arriver
en france je ne sais pas il ya un
clavier qui devrait arriver également
aussi mais une fois de plus rien et
traduit vous le voyez style s il vous
montre donc deux boutons ici au niveau
de votre stylet vous pourrez faire une
capture d'écran avec le bouton arrière
écrire avec le bouton avant et vous avez
la partie qui bordent alors le clavier
on le voit là c'est écrit en chinois
dessous c'est un clavier qwerty qui
borde et note connected mais pourtant il
est écrit en français en dessous donc je
sais pas je pense à tout qui va
également arriver très prochainement ce
qu'on voit ce qu avec ce clavier n'y a
pas de trackpad est ce qui est très
drôle ce qui nous marque de souris est
pavé tactile vitesse du pointeur donc
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un autre système
apparaissent qu'on peut venir connecter
une souris bluetooth pour l'instant j'ai
pas des infos mais ça me paraîtrait
assez normal d'autant plus que d'autres
marques le fond après on est sur un
android de base donc on n'a pas de
tiroirs d'applications mais si vous
venez chercher c'est toute une partie
recherche sur le bas alors vous n'êtes
pas te tuera d'application oui et non
vous pouvez avoir un tiroir
d'applications pour ça il faut aller sur
écran d'accueil vous allez sur écran
d'accueil vous avez classique ou alors
avec le tiroir de l'application et la
voiture ward application vous retrouver
vous êtes toutes vos applis sont rangés
la classe également par catégorie
communication divertissement
photographie outils nouvelle lecture
jeux mode de vie bref c'est très très
très pratique si vous êtes en mode
tiroirs d'application à bien vos
applications ne sont plus là elles sont
rangées en bas directement à vous avez
juste les applications que vous venez
vous monter ici mais par contre si vous
enlevez le tiroir d'applications vos
applications reviennent et vous les avez
toute la donc ça c'est vraiment à vous
de voir ce qui vous intéresse c'est ce
qui vous plaît plus garder pour
l'expérience de navigation sur facebook
c'est vachement fluide va super vite
c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper
agréable c'est ça qui est intéressant
avec le sens d'ailleurs la même chose
sur instagram dans notification ensemble
de contrôles vous avez le panneau de
notification par défaut il est mis sur
android je vous préviens le
personnaliser en disant je veux pas une
notification me voyais ça doit changer
légèrement l'apparence ça mettra des
icônes un peu plus grosse n'y a rien de
bien différent ici on va laisser sur mes
ouailles vous avez autre chose qu'à
c'est rigolo sur les paramètres
supplémentaires vous venez ici et dans
les paramètres supplémentaires vous avez
un embellissement pour les appels vidéo
utilisée beauty faille pour les appels
vidéo wii chat on va tout l'expérience
logiciel vient de chine alors peut-être
pour tous les gens qui vont utiliser
which had dans le monde entier mais en
tout cas nous ici en france c'est pas
l'application convenir utiliser le plus
pour toute l'expérience de gaming c'est
vachement toi ça répond vraiment
vraiment bien ça c'est tout l'intérêt
d'avoir un processeur comme celui là
qu'il a vraiment viré à portée de la
performance derrière ce taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 m ceci apporte
vraiment vraiment vraiment quelque chose
toujours dans ses paramètres
supplémentaires vous avez un mode
entreprises en bas alors ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça demande
vraiment cette tablette elle est faite
également pour des entreprises pour une
flotte de commerciaux télécharger des
vidéos et des photos à partir des
réseaux sociaux donc prévenir les
charger directement donc là par exemple
j'en sais rien si vous êtes sur
instagram et bien priori vous montre
pour venir récupérer vos photos que ce
soit sur instagram whatsapp trop
facebook économiseur d'état ou whatsapp
enregistrer des images et des vidéos à
partir des statuts whatsapp hockey
fichiers privés gérer les fichiers sur
votre appareil et rendait les privés
navigateur me donc vous avez un
navigateur également dormi vous acceptez
vous continuez donc là il faut une
licence que l'entreprise code licence
après tour est des fonctionnalités c'est
assez standard vous et votre compte
niveau compte votre compte google si
vous connaissez tout l'univers logiciel
de chez home ici vous serez pas du tout
dépaysé la vraie question à se poser
tout de suite c est ce que cette
tablette est fait pour vous est ce que
vous êtes dans la ssi pour venir acheter
une tablette à 350 euros jeu sans aucun
problème l'expérience au plus avec ce
grand écran de 11 pouces wqs des plus
120 hertz au niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement et bien c'est super
bien produit gaming dès lors vous avez
un jeu qui va accepter dû s'en va
ailleurs que vous allez avoir une
expérience qui va être beaucoup plus
fluide alors moi je suis aux mines
raconte tient monsieur breda 4 haut
parleurs là dessus je vous dis je mens
bien en terme d'immersion ils ont taillé
un truc un petit peu embêtant lorsque
vous venez regarder un film une série
que vous le tenez comme ça en format
paysage est bien c'est que vos mains en
bas elles viennent bloquer les
haut-parleurs du bas donc il faut
laisser un petit creux lorsque vous le
tenez ce qui fait qu'on tient moins bien
on tient fait entre deux doigts et on
vient de caler légèrement vers bat pour
que ça fasse caisse de résonance et que
ça vous voit le son vers vous parce que
si vous le tenez comme ça fermement et
bien vous obstruer les haut-parleurs du
bail vous empêchait le son d'un rennais
jusqu'à vous ça s'est un peu ballot mais
si le clavier sort en france je ne sais
pas tout de suite en tout cas s'il
arrive il y avait des pouvoirs le poser
sur un clavier ou sinon qu'à des
systèmes de cheval et qui existent pour
venir le poser le cas les sites où vous
permettra de vous dégager de tout ce
type de contrainte en tout cas pan du
visionnage de films de séries par contre
pour de gaming là je me suis fait
notamment des partis d'asphalt 9 eh bien
vous le tenez comme ça vous avez besoin
de manipuler à l'écran alors il faut
faire attention à vous trouver la bonne
technique sans quoi vous voulez bloquer
une fois de plus c'est haut parleurs la
limite au niveau du multimédia ce avec
l' écoute de musique sur spotify par
exemple je me suis mis de la musique les
haut parleurs fonctionne bien mais on
reste quand même vraiment dans le médium
on va pas voir un spectre est large on
va pas avoir un son de très bonne
qualité c'est une tablette à 350 euros
on va pas lui demander la lune lorsque
vous avez beaucoup de lumière et bien je
trouve qu'elle fait vraiment le taf
aussi alors c'est pas la même contrainte
qu'on va voir avec le smartphone on va
se dire eh bien on va l'emmener dehors
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de lumière dont
c'est vrai c'est pas exactement la même
chose néanmoins on veut pouvoir la
regarder lorsqu'on en extérieur et par
exemple sur les beaux jours alors il ya
une techno qui est intéressante et si tu
sais la technologie trop display qui lui
permettra de s'adapter à la lumière
environnante et même là l'envoyer là je
suis en plein soleil eh bien on voit
bien où pour venir visionner des choses
aussi à l'extérieur ou en plein soleil
ça fera le boulot maintenant la
contrainte c'est comme vous avez une
batterie de 8 720 millions paire eur et
un bloc de charge rapide de 22 points 5
watts et bien avec une grosse batterie
comme ça ce n'est plus la charge rapide
autant le 22.3 c'est la charge rapide
avec un smartphone avec des batteries de
4500 millions paire eur aud temps avec
une batterie de 8700 20 millions période
ça marche alors ça va marcher ou de
recharger son problème par contre ça va
mettre plus de temps à côté de ça at on
réellement besoin de recharger une
tablette de 0 à 100 % en 30 minutes je
ne suis pas sûr pour une tablette de 10
pouces on aurait pu espérer avoir une
batterie un peu plus grosses huiles et
720 millions perreur ok dites vous bien
que si vous faites des grandes sessions
gaming et des grandes sessions de
visionnage vous allez rapidement venir
taquiner du chargeur maintenant la
question c'est qu'est ce que moi je vais
me refaire cette tablette est ce que
cette tablette elle est faite pour moi
si vous êtes dans l'univers shiomi et si
vous avez un smartphone de chez ont mis
autant les verts une tablette de chiens
oui pourquoi parce que vous connaissez
déjà loes vous connaissez déjà la marque
et j'imagine que shiomi va aller
beaucoup plus loin vers une
interconnexion entre ces différents
appareils en transe mart phone est une
tablette c'est la notion d'écosystème
que beaucoup de marques développent ce
soit des samsung que ce soit huawei que
ce soit apple et xiaomi aussi le but ça
c'est l'écho si ça mais vous savez c'est
toute la stratégie des marques
aujourd'hui de se dire je vous prends
pas un smartphone et ensuite vous vendre
un ordinateur une telle est une tablette
parce que tout est interconnecté alors
je dirais que c'est encore un peu
différent chez android parce que vous
avez la base d'android à la différence
des os ou c'est que l'ios étaient toutes
superbes et d'optimiser en tout cas ici
ça va être un peu plus ouvert mais
malgré tout des marques xiaomi où les
autres vont tout faire pour que vous
achetiez les autres produits pour cet
écosystème cet inter compatibilité alors
moi cette tablette je trouve intéressant
se trouve intéressant pour plusieurs
choses la toute première c'est la
première tablette de choc c'est l'appât
de 5 alors c'est la toute première en
france on voit que c'est pas la peine 1
c'est pas la patte 2 pas là pas de 3 pas
la patte 4 c'est la patte 5 et puisque
c'est là pas de 5 ça veut dire qu'un
oeil d'autres mais il n'a pas eu d'autre
ici donc c'est la première en france le
design est très sympa alors me direz
vous on est sur une tablette ne l'est
pas vous balader dans la rue avec un
smartphone de la même manière dans le
visage on se fiche un petit peu ce qui
est intéressant c'est que l art est très
sympa très équilibré vous avez un très
très très joli produit à 350 euros sur
la version de base et 399 euros sur la
version un peu plus boosté et bien vous
avez quand même un processeur de la
série 8 de qualcomm vous avez un écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz vous avez une diagonale de 11
pouces vous avez une résolution en wqs
des plus la batterie n'est pas la plus
grosse mais une fois de plus on va
rester à la maison qu'on va venir se
charger dès qu'on aura besoin donc ça me
conviendra ici pas de 5g donc pas de
mobilité ou alors uniquement avec du
partage de connexion si toutefois le
clavier et le style est arrivée en
france ce n'est pas ces informations
tout de suite peut-être que ce sera dit
lors de la conférence mais pour
l'instant je n'ai pas ces informations
eh bien ça sera intéressant parce que
les pouvoir venir prendre des notes
alors attention ne pensez pas que vous
allez à votre stylet pour venir faire du
super travail d'infographie comme on
pourrait le faire avec un ipad pro ou
avec des tablettes beaucoup plus haut de
gamme c'est pas le but c'est pas ça mais
si ça sera surtout de la prise de notes
un peu de croquis ça sera bien pour des
commerces ce sera bien pour des
étudiants pour venir prendre des cours
pour venir faire une productivité
familiale à la maison pour du
divertissement mais pas plus 350 euros
une fois de plus on repositionne mais si
une tablette le trouve polyvalente que
je trouve performante que je trouve
intéressante si vous êtes dans
l'écosystème shiomi si vous aimez la
marche et au mit et bien que pas de sens
que c'est pas mal du tout donc si elle
vous bol je vous mets un lien en bas
dans la description est pas tout de
suite tout de suite parce que je n'ai
pas mais en tout cas ça ne saurait
tarder et cette tablette maintenant il
faudrait que je rendais chez lui parce
que sinon
des problèmes allez bisous
[Musique]